primeiro queria agradecer muito pelo
convite
eu estou aprendendo muito aqui e estou
muito feliz de estar em uma cidade que
não conhecia que de alguma maneira agora
já faz parte da minha história também
não queria muito agradecer vocês
cria também começar compartilhando uma
palavra é só uma pessoa que ama muitas
palavras uma palavra que faz muito
sentido pra mim e faz muito sentido para
tudo o que a gente está de alguma
maneira falando hoje para todos na
reflexão sobre educação e vai costurar
um tanto da minha fala eu quero
compartilhar essa palavra com vocês e
convidar vocês repetirem ela porque é
uma palavra que quando a gente brinca
com ela ela ganha outro sentido
então o convite pra gente repetir a
palavra menor menor
vou começar ea gente segue aqui menor
menor e menor menor e menor menor e
menor menor e menor menor menor e menor
menor menor e menor
eu aprendi essa palavra com o marcelino
freire um poeta brasileiro que também
brinca com as palavras e eu sinto que a
gente vive num contexto em que o brincar
também um ato político em um ato
político importante então por isso o
comércio com essa palavra porque o que
eu vou compartilhar com vocês é algo
pequeno mas grande ao mesmo tempo pra
começar essa história eu tenho uma foto
aqui que é uma imagem da entrada da casa
da minha avó lá em paripiranga na bahia
não sei se alguém aqui já ouviu falar
dessa cidade mas é uma cidade que tem
muito a ver com
minhas raízes minha voz de lá meus avós
meus pais e de alguma maneira
ter essa imagem aqui diante de vocês têm
a ver com compartilhar um pouco da minha
intimidade e muito do que eu vou falar
aqui sobre educação tem a ver com
intimidade como que a gente consegue
criar mais intimidade com o brasil
porque de alguma maneira a gente
aprendeu de uma forma muito violenta a
desvalorizar o que existe no brasil o
que é brasileiro o que se faz de
diferente aqui e eu começo aqui com essa
imagem porque foi lá com a minha avó que
eu olhei por exemplo um dia uma
lagartixa magath já estava lá
numa dessas festas e lagartixa mexer a
cabeça assim é a minha avó falou a
catende que é o nome das lagartixas sabe
tudo
ela fica assim balançando a cabeça
olhando pra você porque ela sabe que
você não sabe tudo de alguma maneira
existe uma quantidade infinita de
saberes que infelizmente a gente ainda
pisa neles gente ainda pisa a gente
ignora eu trago essa história da
intimidade porque essa palavra aprendi
com paulo freire
outra palavra que é importante
compartilhar aqui com vocês com mais
ênfase o paulo freire
quando ele voltou do exílio ele passou
vários anos no exílio na época da
ditadura militar
porque ele foi muito perseguido ele foi
considerado perigoso para o brasil
paulo foi quando ele volta ele dá uma
entrevista para uma rádio e perguntam
pra ele
paulo freire agora que está voltando pra
cá
depois de vários anos fora que você vai
fazer quais são seus projetos no que
você vai está envolvido
ele falou assim eu preciso
de um tempo pra resgatar a minha
intimidade com o brasil porque não tem
como fazer nenhum projeto nenhum sonho
motor pia
se a gente não tem intimidade com a
nossa realidade eu lembro que essa
expressão uma expressão ficou muito
tatuada na minha cabeça porque essa
intimidade com a realidade tem a ver com
a memória tem a ver com a história tem a
ver com o passado
o millôr fernandes ele dizia que o
brasil ainda tem muito passado pela
frente de alguma maneira a gente tem
muitas dívidas com o passado e
reconhecesse passado é muito importante
foi tentando entender que mundo é esse
em que a gente vive que eu junto com
alguns amigos
comecei um projeto no qual a gente
viajou não só pelo brasil mas por outros
países também aqui são alguns lugares
pelos quais a gente passou ea gente
viajou por meio de um projeto financiado
coletivamente mais 500 pessoas apoiaram
essa nossa jornada ea gente saiu
buscando buscando história buscando
pessoas que estão apontando outros
caminhos para a educação que estão
afirmando que na prática hoje já existe
uma outra realidade muito viva muito
impressionante de se ver e de se
constatar que já é palpável
a gente passou por muitos lugares a
gente passou pelo brasil pela argentina
a gente passou na indonésia pela índia
pela áfrica do sul pela suécia pela
inglaterra pela espanha nos estados
unidos e é muito forte porque ainda que
a gente tenha passado por todos esses
países a maior constatação a mais clara
e mais nítida estrondosos a é que a
gente não valoriza o que existe no
brasil é muito impressionante porque
depois de fazer esse projeto que virou
um livro que está disponível em
a net se chama volta ao mundo em três
escolas
várias pessoas vêm perguntar nossa como
são as escolas na europa nós o que está
acontecendo lá na finlândia ea nossa
mais viva resposta é que no brasil está
acontecendo muita coisa a gente precisa
olhar para aí pra isso no brasil tem
crianças que lá no vale do jequitinhonha
estão adotando ruas então renomeando
essas ruas estão fazendo várias ações
pra ocupar o espaço público de uma
maneira diferente no brasil tem uma
escola no capão redondo em são paulo na
qual quando eu fui conversar com uma
senhora de uns 60 anos sessenta e cinco
anos mais ou menos
ela falou assim aqui nessa escola
eu descobri pela primeira vez que eu
podia sonhar e aí eu descobri depois
disso que eu podia sonhar ainda mais
isso também é muito forte para a gente
como é um lugar que afirma no corpo de
alguém que é possível sonhar mas não só
que é possível sonhar mas que é possível
sonhar ainda mais a gente sabe que
quando a gente olha pra outras formas de
educação outro jeito de aprender a gente
está colocando em xeque esse outro jeito
de aprender que gera falas como a de uma
garota que um dia eu encontrei ela falou
assim se eu fosse diretora da minha
escola eu explodi a escolhe a construir
um shopping no lugar ou outra fala
também ficou muito forte pra mim que de
um educador colombiano que ele em uma
conversa com algumas crianças fez uma
espécie de dicionário com um significado
de palavras que crianças falaram para
ele ao longo de alguns anos ea ele ouviu
de uma criança que a definição de corpo
é a seguinte o corpo é uma partida
cabeça de alguma maneira a gente sabe a
urgência ética de encontrar outras
maneiras de se relacionar encontrar
outras maneiras de aprender juntos de
aprender juntas e isso tem a ver com a
intimidade de novo essa intimidade com a
realidade
teve um dia que eu tava numa escola
pública e era hora do lanche e nesse dia
ela macarrão com almôndegas ao macarrão
comum deles eu sempre estudei em escolas
públicas sempre gostei muito do macarrão
comum de gum não é do intervalo mas eu
me tornei vegetariano e aí nesse dia eu
estava nessa escola eu falei para
merendeira que eu não ia como el mundo e
ganhou começar o macarrão
ela já se assustou neto ou não meu filho
tenha mondego aqui como é o mundo
eu peguei só o macarrão saí fui pra mesa
eu não sou muito dia lá de ar e se sabe
a opção pelo por ser vegetariana mas
nesse dia as pessoas viram né tava claro
que estava sem ao mundo em uma garota
quando olhou o meu prato ea gente estava
numa mesa assim grande com vários várias
crianças
eu acho que se tivesse uma foto de cima
assim ver vários pratos com molho em um
só sem essa garota olhou pra mim assim
for não acredito acabaram as almôndegas
não acredito k várias ondas
eu falei 'não não acabar é um deles
na verdade eu não pedi as almôndegas é
que eu sou vegetariano
ela falou vegetariano vegetariana e ela
perguntou mas vegetariano fala português
aí eu contei que deu trabalho pra
aprender que não é assim tão fácil e
leva alguns anos mas eu consegui na
medida
possível né comentou ainda os deslizes e
essa história ficou muito marcada pra
mim como esse fato de que quando a gente
não conhece
uma coisa é como se essa coisa falasse
outra língua
essa imagem ficou muito forte pra mim
quando a gente não conhece uma coisa
como essa coisa falar se uma outra
língua
de novo como a gente cria intimidade com
a nossa realidade como a gente cria
intimidade com o brasil para que o
brasil não pareça um lugar onde se fala
outra língua para que as pessoas que
estão perto da gente não pareçam pessoas
que falam uma outra língua ainda que
claro existem as diferenças todas mas
esse ponto dessa dessa metáfora quando
trazendo aqui é como a gente fica mais
perto como a gente consegue se aproximar
como a gente consegue escutar mesmo com
essas diferenças
nessas viagens todas era muito
impressionante quando eu por exemplo no
chile
descobrir a gabriela mistral que é uma
educadora uma poeta incrível ela ganhou
o prêmio nobel de literatura é a única
mulher latino americana que ganhou um
prêmio nobel de literatura e no brasil
que a gente está aqui pertinho pertinho
de lá a gente não conhece ela
no geral a gente não conhece ela o mesmo
quando eu fui para a europa e lá e me
perguntavam do paulo freire falavam
nossa você vem do país em que paulo
freire viveu conta pra mim como é essa
honra
eu falava o ao uaw como a gente precisa
disso como a gente precisa reconhecer
essa história como a gente precisa viver
isso no corpo para que se esteja com a
gente de verdade uma outra história que
foi vivida
logo depois do livro aqui são algumas
fotos vocês podem encontrar esse livro
na internet como eu já disse e volto
em três escolas logo depois do livro
junto com alguns amigos a gente criou um
projeto chamado virá da educação que
envolveu muitas escolas e que até hoje
envolve algumas escolas públicas de são
paulo e que envolve também coletivos em
outros estados ea gente fez algumas
dessas saídas pelas ruas muito nesse
movimento de tentar entender como a
gente pode ocupar os territórios como a
gente pode criar no corpo memórias vivas
de que é possível está no mundo de outra
maneira e teve um dia que depois de uma
dessas saídas em que a gente foi com
maracatu na rua em que a gente estava
cantando em que a gente estava brincando
em que a gente estava fazendo esse ato
político também de estar na cidade sendo
cidadão já de uma maneira muito ativa
desde os 56 anos
logo depois de uma dessas saídas na qual
as pessoas que estavam em um prédio elas
em alguns prédios nelas olhavam pela
janelas e teve um momento que elas
começaram a bater palmas
imaginem como essa cena de você está na
rua com vários amigos seus várias amigas
com adultos com crianças com jovens e
você tá lá e as pessoas estão batendo
palma porque você está na rua
logo depois disso a gente fez uma roda
de conversa com as crianças ea gente
perguntou é o que ficou mais marcante
que foi mais forte pra vocês e as
crianças falaram uma delas na verdade
falou eu vi as pessoas
eu vi os carros e eu vi a rua e essa
criança abriu os braços quando ela falou
rua e não parecia só falar que a rua é
grande
era abraçar a rua e aí de novo tem a ver
com intimidade como a gente cria
intimidade com a rua como agente
criatividade com quem está perto
a gente cria intimidade com a nossa
história a última coisa que vou contar
aqui quando era adolescente meu tempo
acabou inclusive quando era adolescente
eu tinha mais tempo do que eu tenho
agora aqui e eu enviava cartas pelas
pessoas
eu pegava endereços às vezes eu estava
na rua encontrar uma revista
pegava o endereço qualquer não sabia
quem era a pessoa eu escrevi uma carta
para ela lá eu sou o andré gravatá
gostaria de conversar com você se você
tiver disponível foi poder escrever uma
carta pra mim eu vou ficar muito feliz e
eu mandei muitas cartas porque na época
descobriu um selo que custava um centavo
então eu lá na periferia embu das artes
de nordestinos em dinheiro ea com 50
centavos nos correios e me sentia o
imperador dos selos e da possibilidade
de me comunicar com as pessoas que eu
mandei muitas cartas e eu não recebi
muitas respostas
ainda que eu tenho recebido algumas e
foi muito forte essa experiência para
mim porque de alguma maneira eu sinto
que já um lá nesse momento eu estava
tentando entender o que é isso que a
gente chama de aproximação que isso que
a gente chama de intimidade e como isso
é importante como isso é importante
principalmente no tempo presente em que
o que se coloca é o afastamento
então deixo aqui com vocês esse convite
firme muito firme de mais intimidade com
a nossa realidade e de uma percepção
também muito intensa de que isso é menor
menor e menor menor e menor menor e
menor